no I hold up rice all looks like there's
nothing romantic going on between Noah
Beck and James Charles I was single
always yeah even though the two looks
super close here here and here Noah and
James are just friends of course I would
love to have a boyfriend one day the
dating rumors started when Bryce posted
this YouTube video titled Noah Beck is
dating James Charles I know James is
filming a YouTube video right now we're
totally gonna interrupt this because I
think then moments later James posted
this tick tock video dancing with Noah
naturally fans went crazy in the comment
section so Noah had to set the record
straight writing bro we are just two
friends dancing and smiling then the
YouTube star clarified he's straight and
to stop assuming things when you have no
idea this comes just days after Blake
great eased an upcoming collab we never
knew we needed
yep that's Blake Bryce Noah
Jaden hustler Josh Richards and Griffin
Johnson teaming up for a brand new video
with James Blake captioned the pic
filming with this sister all the boys
are staying inside filming content the
quarantine definitely has tested our
creative ability okay we are totally
here for right I definitely am a
workaholic self-proclaimed
I'm insulted nose for sore but it's kind
of good I'm usually running on
to reality sleep knocks but it's kind of
fun this isn't the first time James
teamed up with some famous tick stalkers
21 year old filmed with Addison Rae Adam
Martinez and Charlie D'Amelio the social
media influencers spilled some major
tease so we know the sway house boys
will totally deliver
[Music]